the Joe Rogan experience starting
February 8th I will be gaining weight
and you guys will be losing weight at
first month against me right yeah great
they'll be dumped my special okay first
one to pass me I'll weigh in every day
so I'm gonna get down to 190 but you'll
pass me first but you're starting in
I'll be in check wait what do you think
you can get up - I've been up top I've
been to 40 before Wow
pull that picture up Jamie I remember I
remember those in college oh no no you
got fat I got I know I've been like 220
oh yeah I remember
and these eatin candy she's eating candy
all day a lot of candy Lana can be all
right and then he just quit eatin candy
and I was like that [ __ ] got a
willpower that's one thing when we did
this over October fitness challenge
honestly like legitimately Ari was the
only one I was worried about why cuz
you're crazy does I remember I
remembered you and you said when you
lose I know you don't like to lose yeah
you get very serious we play pool and
even though I'm a better pool player
than Ari I would give him the 7 8 & 9 we
were Campbell so we play 9-ball and I'd
have to run all the balls and sink to 9
to win but Ari could win if he sunk the
seven the eight or the nine it's a giant
advantage is a huge difference and we're
playing he would get very competitive
and then I bought him a year Jiu Jitsu
once for Christmas or Hanukkah or
whatever the [ __ ] you celebrate and you
know it's Hanukkah whatever it's
nonsense he's not so sure
anyway so we were doing jujitsu in here
it got [ __ ] very serious like we were
rolling together like he's really trying
well he's very competitive our he's very
good but like he's got a very strong
mind and I was like this mother we're
not doing anything we're like you have
to get better at a physical skill or you
know you have to do so it's it's it's
very simple all you have to do is have
willpower to stay at 80% of your max
heart rate for a long time and that's
all willpower that's really all it is or
if you're smart enough
distract yourself like far we figured
out how to watch movies that was a big
game changer and the [ __ ] thing on
the strap yeah once you figured out how
to watch movies while you're on the
treadmill yeah it wasn't annoying to
have to constantly be like that
challenge part none of us expected that
to tell all of us to go for it it was so
first off each other it was so crazy
when you got the flu and then you came
back from the flu in round 13 [ __ ]
miles that's why this year that's that's
little competition cuz everybody's
girlfriend or wives was like no no no
yeah everybody up man the whole family
yeah plus I was just crazy man I was so
into it I just like opened up that door
I opened up that door that I didn't I
hadn't opened up that door and [ __ ]
decades who do you think will pass me
first and wait between the two of you me
you think him too
hmm yeah I'll just become obsessive
compulsive about it hmm it's uh it's not
super fun but I'm cool with it if I know
got nothing to do do it and how far you
gonna get I mean hopefully one of them
stop them how great would it be if we
didn't lose anyways carry your 180 you
have to gain 25 pounds just to get the
birds target weight oh my god wait to
just I want you to look at this someone
should if they go that way you're right
what Tom might have done something a
little early that we'll talk about in a
minute but this stacks of stakes I was
in the bathroom what the [ __ ] happened I
don't know Jamie what Jamie what
happened you [ __ ] I thought you
[ __ ] I didn't do any what you saw the
way and you walked in stock tailing it
number Oh watch the video tomorrow this
is [ __ ]
he leaned on my shoulder
wait how'd you notice my idea wasn't
well you got lucky you don't do for
summer October this year I remember now
you're gonna say today I saw Tom
weighing in and I went oh that's why I
should weigh in he's weighing in you
[ __ ]
yeah I would never do something like
that
[Applause]